[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
the evidence found in the heartbreaking
murder of an iowa college student out
jogging
did christian pogena rivera kill molly
tibbetts and leave her body in a
cornfield
we had a hard time finding something
negative about molly tibbetts
mother of five jennifer doulos
disappeared two years ago
a sneak peek into the new movie and
documentary about her life
and presumed murder she's angry she
knows she's got a problem and then
suddenly this guy
turns on the charm to bring her back in
that 70s show actor danny masterson
is ordered to stand trial for three
charges of forcible rape
why a jury could hear evidence about the
church of scientology
doomsday called mom lori valodebel is
declared indigent
as her defense attorney agrees to keep
representing her and
prosecutors try to link the murder of
robert durst's best friend
to the disappearance of his first wife
in 1982.
was the millionaire real estate air
abusive to kathy durst law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
prosecutors have rested in the iowa
murder trial of a college student found
dead in a cornfield
law and crime's angenette levy is here
to explain why where molly tibbetts dna
was discovered
is so important yeah brian dna is really
a key part of this case
along with the statement of christian
bahina rivera to law enforcement
this cornfield became a crime scene on
august 21
2018 after investigators said christian
bahina rivera led them to the area where
he left mollie tibbetts's body
and covered it in corn stalks crime
scene technician amy johnson found
tibbetts as black running shorts and
underwear nearby she also examined
bahina rivera's trunk
and found blood in four areas it was the
rubber seal located
near the license plate area on the rear
of the vehicle
dna analyst tara scott tested that stain
the dna profile that i developed matched
the known dna profile of mollie tibbetts
scott said she also found another spot
on the trunk liner
after prosecutors asked her to
re-examine it
the profile that i developed indicated a
mixture of three individuals
i was able to determine a partial
profile at 20
out of the 21 locations that i tested of
the major contributor
and that was consistent with the known
dna profile
of mollie tibbetts scott said there were
other blood stains found in the trunk
but the dna was simply too weak to
develop a profile
something the defense focused on during
cross-examination
i cannot include or exclude anybody from
those
mixtures now you can't exclude christian
beginner rivera from that
i cannot include or exclude bahina
rivera's attorney also raised the
possibility that mollie tibbetts blood
could have been placed in the trunk by
someone else
dna won't tell us how it got there right
correct won't
tell us if it was transferred there will
it well not
will not tell us if it was dropped there
right correct won't tell us if it was
scraped on there
right correct just tells us what it is
yes
and the special prosecutor in this case
seemed to get a little agitated
when the lead state agent on the case
testified
agent trent valletta said that they
looked into a number of other suspects
possible suspects in this case including
molly tibbetts
boyfriend but he said they didn't find
any evidence
tying any of those other individuals to
her disappearance
were you able to develop any information
from any of the men
including dalton jack
any information from any of those men
that they made admissions
that molly tibbetts was in the trunk of
their car
no just christian rivera is the only one
that told us that
that puts her in the trunk agreed yes
does it put him stabbing her
all right no okay
and the prosecutor then asked whether or
not heyna rivera claimed
that he had blacked out at some point
during his interaction with mollie
tibbetts when he became angry and he
confirmed that that was indeed true
brian thanks angeannette joining us
today is criminal defense attorney
anna young and terry austin and uh
multiple sources of dna in beijing
rivera's car and potential contamination
how do the defense's arguments
uh hold up after cross you know i think
the defense brian is trying to work with
what they have here
and i think the defense attorney made
some good points when he was saying
listen
you don't know how the dna got there you
don't know how it got transferred there
you don't know if it was
placed there we just know that in some
portions the dna was found there so i
think again
he's using what he has but the fact that
there's dna in that car that's pretty
damning evidence and that's a big
strength for the prosecution yeah terry
talking about damning evidence
tibbetts blood in the trunk fits the
confession could tippett's blood
being in the car tie this case all
together when you think of all of the
testimony
it could and you know brian the job of
the prosecutor is to tie
all the evidence together so they don't
have the actual confession because
that was actually omitted because of the
miranda warnings
but they have rivera admitting both to
agent valletta and to the interpreter
romero
that he led them to where the body was
and he explained
you know how it occurred so they have
that and the prosecution can tie that
together
that along with the blood in the trunk
and one last thing brian
none of the other witnesses ever talked
about
leading them to the crime scene none of
the other suspects so i think if the
prosecution
can tie all that together they will have
a good case
now anjanet the defense also questioned
the dna analyst
about dna in the home where molly
tibbetts was staying right
that's right and they're trying to raise
this possibility that there was another
man
that no one knows about or somebody that
could have
attacked her in her home and taken her
out of the home against her will
they questioned the dna analyst about an
arnold palmer
drink can that they um swabbed within
the home
where molly tibbetts was staying that's
where she was living with not only her
boyfriend but his brother and his
his fiance and they said that there was
an unknown male
profile a dna profile on that can and it
was a mixture with
molly tibbetts his dna we don't know
whose that was though and they did not
take dna samples from the boyfriend
or his brother all right like as we said
the prosecution has arrested the next
step is potentially to see
whether or not the defense puts on a
case of course we'll give you that
update as it comes along
thank you everyone still ahead on law
and crime daily the new order from the
presiding judge in the doomsday cult
duo case but first the disappearance of
a connecticut model five
two years ago we speak to dan abrams
about his new movie and documentary
coming out about the jennifer doulo's
case
next
[Music]
welcome back a connecticut mother was
last seen alive two years ago
a new movie looking into the jennifer
dillo's case by law and car productions
is set to premiere on lifetime and we've
got a sneak peek for you right here
i love fotus i want to have a family
with him
this morning father of five jennifer
doulas was reported missing
based on the true story you need to find
her husband that shook the nation
whatever happened to jennifer
he is behind it annabeth gish
warren christie people make all sorts of
horrible assumptions
they don't know me i'm innocent gone bob
the disappearance of jennifer doulas
premieres june 5th only on lifetime
the story of missing mom jennifer doulos
has captured headlines
here at the law and crime network
joining me now is the founder of the law
and crime network and executive producer
dan abrams
so this is based on the very high
profile story of a
mother of five who disappears and
it becomes increasingly evident that the
police are focusing
on her ex potus doulas and
the story kind of unravels as time goes
on
jennifer was last seen dropping her kids
off at school on may 24th
2019. police believe her estranged
husband photos dullos killed her
her body has never been found i mean
photos doulos
had a bad temper and you see that in the
film and jennifer doulos
you know was put in a horrible situation
she became a victim of
of domestic violence surveillance
cameras captured photos dulos and his
then girlfriend michelle troconis
dumping trash bags on the day jennifer
disappeared there are five children
who are alive today who don't have a
mother or a father
and we try to be as best we can
respectful of that fact
now then with so many questions still
being asked in this case
where does this movie start and where
does it kind of take us through
on this journey yeah so it look it
starts from
uh the perspective of jennifer and she
is
talking about how she you know she could
use a break
she could use an opportunity to go to
the beach
etc she was a prolific writer so what
the producers here
tried to do is to tell the story in part
through jennifer's own words the words
the thoughts that might have been going
through jennifer's mind
um at the time and this is you know
shortly before
things go go south now gone mom is the
movie but you're also taking viewers
through an inside look into the case in
a new documentary called
beyond the headlines the jennifer
doulo's story how are you bringing this
grouping story to life
in a documentary so in the um
in the lifetime movie you see actors
and in particular one central character
playing her best friend but
in the documentary you see that that
character was
actually based on a number of her
closest friends
each of them providing a really unique
insight
into jennifer into her relationship with
photos etc
and that's all in the in the documentary
version of the uh of the story
jennifer's family have released a
statement on the second anniversary of
her believed death
although this past year has
understandably slowed the process
the investigation into jennifer's death
and disappearance is ongoing
after the courts reopen the two people
charged with conspiracy to murder
will stand trial photo's dulos was
charged along with michelle trucones and
friend ken mahini
doulos died of an apparent suicide last
january mahini and troconis are awaiting
trial for conspiracy of murder charges
draconis is due in court on tuesday
back with us criminal defense attorney
anna young and terry austin
terry in the two years since jennifer
deulos's disappearance what has been the
biggest twist in this investigation
no doubt the biggest twist is the fact
that we now have fotus dulo gone he
is now you know committed suicide and
they won't be able to
try him for the crime of potentially
killing his wife
and not having him available means that
they can't use one
against the other so i think that's
probably the
biggest issue that the case is going to
have to face and the question is whether
or not there's ever going to be
justice as far as jennifer is concerned
yeah and
anna not having photos do those does a
number of things because right now we
only have kent mohani
and michelle troconis being set to try
now we've seen
cases where there are murder trials
without the body and those are hard but
what about
murder conspiracy to commit murder
without a body
is that harder right excellent question
i think
absolutely if there's a murder charge
without a body those cases are so
difficult to prove for the prosecution
but i think it's going to be a little
bit easier for the prosecution in the
sense that they're charging them with
conspiracy
right so they're going to be focusing on
the efforts that were made the overt
acts that were made between these two
defendants
to show that they had a plan in place
that they were conspiring
to get this done and of course they're
going to rely upon things such as
the alibi script and and the cell phone
pinging and any kind of communications
between the two now
of course like terry was saying more
difficult because float is not there
but at the end of the day i think it's
going to be a little bit easier because
it's going to be focusing on the overt x
and not necessarily
the fact there's no body yeah i mean
there's a saying for it at least two
former presidents would agree
it's not always a crime sometimes it's
the cover-up that gets you caught so
we'll see how that plays out as these
two
go towards trial coming up on law and
crime daily the actor ordered to face
trial after three women accuse him of
forcible rape
plus how robert durst's alleged actions
against his missing wife
are coming into trial involving the
murder of his best friend
the new testimony you don't want to miss
[Music]
we're back a judge is ordering actor
danny masterson to stay in trial for
three charges of rape after women
accusing him took the stand at a hearing
saying that that 70s show actor attacked
them
after days of emotional testimony a
california judge ruled three women's
statements
were credible enough to support the
charges the women told the court
masterson raped them
between 2001 and 2003.
the judge said there's evidence the
policies of the church of scientology
discouraged them from reporting to the
police masterson is a prominent
scientologist
and all three women are former
scientologists masterson has pled not
guilty
his defense accuses the women of seeking
financial gain
he's due back in court next month for a
new arraignment masterson faces up to 45
years in prison
if convicted all right let's bring in
criminal defense attorney anna young
and co-host terry austin terry the
allegations by the alleged victims were
enough to bring this case to trial
is any more needed from the prosecution
to get a conviction
or is it all right there yeah you know
probably that's all they're going to get
at this point you know it's been over 20
years
and you're going to have to rely on the
testimony of the witnesses and what they
have to say
i doubt at this point if there is any
dna
evidence unless they were able to
collect some way back when and we
haven't heard
any information in that regard there
could also be
some digital evidence maybe phone
records maybe
text maybe emails but i think again
it's been so long that it might have
been more difficult to gather that type
of information so
i think it's going to be based all on
what witnesses have to say
yeah it could end up really being he
said she said with maybe some
corroboration from outcry witnesses
and the defense is clearly saying the
alleged victims are after the church of
scientology
could the defense drag the church into
the court as a type of
alternative suspect i think the defense
couldn't make that argument and i think
the defense is really going to harp on
what they're saying right now which is
this is
all about money and we know that there's
a civil lawsuit involving the church so
of course they're going to try to drag
the church in and by saying this was the
church it's all about the church this
was not about our client
and our position all along was the fact
that this was consensual sex and to
terry's point it's absolutely right
because so much time has come by
it's really going to be a matter of he
said she said and of course the jury's
going to have to think about
potential underlying motives here yeah
we could
i cause i know for most people the
church of scientology is kind of
shrouded in mystery this could be the
case that pulls back that shroud
and tells us the inner workings of that
church as we see how women and men are
affected in different ways
we see that there may be some rules when
it comes to our rules i'll say
uh to reporting this type of thing so
we'll definitely learn a lot more as
this case continues
when we come back new questions into the
finances of the so-called doomsday cult
mom
lori valodebel one idaho judge's order
on the other
side of the break
welcome back prosecutors in the robert
durst trial are presenting evidence
they say ties the murder of his best
friend to the disappearance of his first
wife
the real estate air is accused of
murdering susan berman back in december
2000
prosecutors alleged durst shot berman
because she knew too much
about the disappearance of durham's
first wife kathy in 1982.
on the fourth day of testimony an
emergency room physician
spoke about treating kathy just one
month before she was last seen alive
given the history and the exam one would
assume it was from inflicted trauma
okay well did you notice any underlying
disease within her body which would have
caused the black eye and just her left
eye
no sir okay in your opinion was this
inflicted upon her
by someone or something yes
was this injury consistent with
being punched in the face or slapped in
the face
yes have you treated domestic violence
victims
in your career in the er yes would you
say hundreds of times
yes was this injury consistent
i'm not saying uh if you know personally
that was caused by but was it consistent
in your experience
with the type of injury you've seen
caused by incidents of domestic violence
it could have been in your experience in
training how recent were these injuries
the fact that there was bruising noted
it would indicate that it was probably
several
hours or longer old
okay well was this days old or within
hours you think
can't tell
anna there are a lot of moving pieces in
this trial alleged domestic violence is
now another
is this painting a large picture for the
jury or could there be too much on this
canvas
you know brian i think there's too much
on this canvas and i think the
prosecution
prosecution is destroying whatever they
can against the wall to see what's stick
because this is going to be a very tough
case for the prosecution keep in mind
the defense is really going to argue the
fact that there's no forensic evidence
here
a lot of time has passed there's no dna
no blood evidence
no fingerprint no weapon these are all
things that the defense attorney
mentioned in his opening statement to
articulate
that this is going to be a case about
pure speculation
and that's what the government is doing
if you see in the testimony could this
have been consistent with her getting a
black guy
sure but even these witnesses are saying
that they don't have an opinion as to
how it got there
so i think that the prosecution is just
working with what they have and throwing
everything up there to see
what they can do to muddy up the
defendant so the jury doesn't like him
and i think that's
what they have to do because they've got
a lot of lack of evidence in my opinion
in this case
and there's definitely a lot there to
make him seem unfavorable to most people
but the question is not about being
unfavorable
it's about being guilty of course we'll
keep eyes on that and law and crimes
got a camera in the robert durst trial
and we gave him you gavel to gavel
coverage on everything robert durst
now to idawa where the so-called
doomsday called mom laurie
de belvalo is being declared indigent
valo and her husband chad dabo are
charged with concealing evidence related
to the deaths
of valo's two children the bodies of
seven-year-old joshua j.j
vallo and 17 year old tyler ryan were
found on dave bell's property
the couple's expected to go to trial
together but have different attorneys
according to a new order valo dabo has
limited funds to pay her attorney
mark means east idaho dot com reports
means will continue to represent her
vowels being held in the madison county
jail she's due back in court on july
12th
terry so she's still going to have this
same defense attorney
but how could being indigent affect
valo's case going forward
you know brian i don't think it's going
to affect the case very much
she is entitled to being declared
indigent and getting assistance if her
income
reaches a certain level or if she's on
public assistance
or if she's currently serving a jail
term or
if she's in a mental institution and i
think based on of
those issues we think that it's probably
because of the
income and so she's entitled under the
code
to everything that you would be entitled
to
if you weren't declared indigent so that
means investigation
that means expert testimony so she'll
get whatever she needs and she's got the
same attorney
so i'm certain he's going to continue on
the path that he already is on
yeah it could this is a very common
thing that people hire attorneys and
they run out of money because it is
expensive
to keep up a criminal case i'm sure many
people are probably
commenting that she wishes she didn't
fly to hawaii right now and maybe saved
a few dollars for this defense
uh but like you said same defense
attorney keep going forward
but they're also gonna get tried with
her with her husband as well correct and
he's got a paid attorney
yeah i mean i'm assuming that he has a
paid attorney obviously he does and that
he's going to continue doing so he
hasn't been declared to our knowledge
indigent as yet all right terry anna
thank you and thank you for joining us
here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you